un minuto de silencio por mí a tweetdeck
in miles de birmanos rindieron homenaje
a la joven de 20 años que perdió la vida
por un disparo en la cabeza y que ahora
se ha vuelto en un símbolo para los
manifestantes en pro de la democracia no
hay posibilidades de que muchas más
personas mueran nosotros mismos ni
siquiera podemos saber si moriremos o no
pero tenemos que luchar hasta el final
independientemente de nuestras vidas por
un éxito que llegará después podemos
deshacernos de esta dictadura militar
son muchos los que siguen uniéndose a la
campaña de desobediencia civil en
protesta contra el golpe militar del
pasado primero de febrero que derrocó la
líder del país en sanssouci y a otros
funcionarios
[Aplausos]
los manifestantes exigen la restauración
del gobierno electo la liberación de
sushi y la eliminación de la
constitución de 2008 redactada bajo la
supervisión militar y que otorga al
ejército un papel importante en la
política de mianmar
13 los militares dijeron que gobernarían
democráticamente pero al mismo tiempo
cortaron la conexión a internet y
bloquearon plataformas de redes sociales
como facebook y twitter
eso significa que sus palabras no
coinciden con sus acciones por lo tanto
nunca les creeremos a la comunidad
internacional ha condenado el uso de la
fuerza contra manifestantes y las
detenciones que ya suman casi 550 en
menos de tres semanas entre ellos
líderes políticos funcionarios monjes y
activistas